they reject nation how's it going we're
gonna do another episode for you guys of
trailers revisited and today we're gonna
do the movie get out I figured why we
would do get out is because the movie
the quiet ones
Oh
being quiet it's coming out on Friday
tfu and I thought it was fascinating how
this movie is getting amazing reviews
and it's from John Krasinski who comes
from a background that's mainly known to
delve a lot more in a comedy and war
movies with Michael yeah but we all know
him as the dude from the office and now
he's got this like Jim awesome horror
movie out and then Jordan Peele who is
known for comedy now has to get out
movie I see what you did there
yeah exactly instead of just watching
the final trailer for we do this one set
but as a heads up when we first did a
trailer reaction to this it got blocked
right away so I don't know if we could
feature the whole trailer but this
videos are not about the reaction to the
trailer it's more about the analysis
part you know where we talk about if
it's spoiler rific if it captures the
tone there's more of a discussion video
anyway so we might have to skip through
some of the reaction part of revisiting
this trailer but I haven't seen this
trailer since before I watched the movie
so it's been a long-ass time
hey let's check it out John you ready
you got your you have your theater
didn't know black you know
this weekend I want you to be shocked
that he's black
oh wow this is this is good
[Music]
[Music]
the chills yeah Bobby show their Joey
[ __ ] hit
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a fascinating trailer yeah right
it's fascinating because always that
it's spoiler filled trailer yet it's
doesn't spoil the movie uses a whole lot
of revealing footage but assembled in an
order where you don't leave going oh I
know exactly what order all this goes in
and there's something about the
immediacy of the pacing of this trailer
that yeah by the time you're done you're
mostly left her for me I'm mostly left
with just like the tone and the impact
although I do remember certain things
that when we were watching the movie
like when the brother when he's gonna
hit him in the head because I'm like oh
yeah I remember the trailer showed that
piece of footage yeah and so I remember
day oh he's gonna break out of that but
I think when I first saw this trailer it
looked like that was all part of his
long hypnosis scene yeah when he was
like seen before because the way they
edit the trailer was like he sneaks into
the floor he's back he's already tied up
yeah so it looks like that's all part of
his hypnosis process but when I was
watching the movie like okay so he's
gonna break out of here yeah the thing
is Caleb Landry Jones does come back he
like you think he's dead but he comes
back in the attacks and so I'm like okay
so I'm that big of a spoiler I remember
the first time they really touched the
hypnosis element it completely caught me
by surprise because they so effortlessly
start to blend in that repetitive sound
and stuff it's really easy in the movie
to forget about some of these moments
because of how gradually and how subtly
they're introduced over time but this
trailer really does reveal is one way
you can argue is it's the plot of the
movie clearly these white people are up
to something and they want Daniel kuya's
character for something the other part
is they kind of show you a lot of how
the first half will play out they
basically give you the the Cliff's Notes
version of the first yeah all the way up
until we heat the stanfield says get out
after that it's kind of a mishmash of I
don't really know exactly when these
events will take place just a hodgepodge
of the WTF moments the thing that the
trailer also ruined for me when I was
watching the movie was what would happen
with Georgina cuz as the movie is going
I remembered oh yeah isn't Georgina like
scream at him in the car then they crash
yeah there's outcomes they don't
like what do they really want with Chris
what's the ultimate plan what happens
we're Georgina and the grandpa also with
rose is Cana miss Lee it's misleading
here because it's still least it makes
it look like Rose is probably still on
her side yes I post teas roast of all
things to not give away I'm pleased they
didn't spoil them because there's even a
quick snippet moment here it's super
like 0.5 seconds maybe less than that
yeah I kept a hard time finding it right
now where you see Rose holding a shotgun
it doesn't say oh she's bad too I'm kind
of surprised it like this is essentially
two-thirds of the movie that they is
they play out for you other than how
exactly it is this all unfolded what is
the overall outcome of it one thing that
I wish this Trevor didn't include was
little rel sane to do research on this
group and apparently a lot of black
people go miss I'm like that's too much
to reveal in the trailer right there I
wish they had held that one because
knowing that piece of information when I
was watching the movie just kept making
me wait for more of the bigger reveal to
keep coming because I was aware that oh
this is a town where black people go
missing and these white people have
something to do with it it puts me less
out of Chris's shoes when I'm aware of a
plot reveal point to come you know that
there's a certain context that's gonna
pop up in it yes at least some of the
mysterious build-up out of the first
half of the movie if you have that
detail in your mind and that sense of
what is going on is like a huge selling
point for so many horror movies and it's
a great way to get people into a
thriller like this the mystery it's
finding I mean what the context is they
don't ruin why they're kidnapping so
many black people they don't ruin that
but they ruin that they're doing that
yeah exactly it doesn't ruin the movie
but it would have been nice to maybe
leave that a mystery the greater
implications of mystery I mean the great
thing about get out is that it's such a
gripping movie and it's got so many
facets yeah it's all and so with about
the details that that's why I'm saying
this is a fascinating trailer because
it's so spoiler if ik yet it doesn't
spoil the movie rarely can you say that
about a trailer No
naturally ruins the whole movie yeah
yeah and I remember that first time we
watched it like I'd still surprised me
at times it still had me completely
pulled in I think that's the thing is
when you're drawing spoiler if ik
moments for your trailer sometimes just
the order you put them in and the
rapidity at which you fire them at us
can make the difference between us
walking away from a trailer going well
now I just saw the movie versus I really
want to see where all that goes yeah and
when those moments occurred if you're
pulled in enough to a movie you'll
forget about upcoming scenes our moments
are like oh wait a minute wasn't the
scene in the trip oh that's probably
gonna come later that yeah mysteries
that don't get to be a hundred percent
histories anymore but otherwise I mean
you know at least in terms of
communicating the tone and you know the
kind of two halves of a movie you're
gonna get it's it's pretty on point
today on point and that's from the most
important quality to it I think it's a
really good trailer these are great
trailer yeah I mean it's a [ __ ] sold
the [ __ ] yeah buddy
trailer plus the word of mouth oh yeah
one day good even that first jump-scare
is like perfectly time I forgot they
included that deer moment and that made
me jump this time
oh yeah because when you're watching the
movie it does feel like you're watching
some other than the prologue setup of
like Heath Stanfield getting kidnapped
they do you have this tone and vibe of
oh you know a couple of gonna go meet
the parents guess who's coming home yeah
okay cool yeah spoiler if you're
triggered it doesn't spoil the movie
witness alright guys what other trailers
do you guys recommend for trailers
revisited we love doing this segment
because it's a really fascinating
analysis that sometimes do so really
appreciate if you guys do some
recommendations down below you can
subscribe and become a part of the
reject nation people do it click that
notification bellow porfavor and you can
check us out on our patreon become a
patreon ejected a full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is would love to
have you be a member of our society yeah
join us I mean